All of Microsoft has blood on its hand.
How dare you ask us why Microsoft is
killing children? Shame on you all.
Thank you.
Islam is raising funds to establish a
masjid and community center in Norway
and they urgently need your support.
This donation will be a for you because
every person that comes a step closer to
Allah through your donation, you will in
be reaping the reward. Click the link
and donate what you can. Asalam
alalaykum brothers and sisters and dear
friends. Hope you guys are well
inshallah. So, subhan Allah. Not all
heroes wear capes. Some of them wear
hijabs. Ahu. Nice. Okay. Subhan Allah,
brothers and sisters. Um, this sister
wall, like I'll be honest with you,
sisters are quite vocal. Alhamdulillah.
You know, they really do a fantastic job
when it comes to voicing their opinions
and you know, mashallah. Um, and in this
very instance, Nice. Is there someone
outside? I think so. All right, let's
go. You not all heroes wear capes. Some
of them wear um hoodies. Go hero and
find out who was it. I will do that.
Nice. In the meantime, guys, I'm going
to carry on the video. This is going to
be actually very interesting. We're
going to watch it in while Zan comes
back and how she confronted this
Mustafa, this shameless man. His name is
an honorable thing. Yes, it's the name
of the prophetam. One of the names. Yes.
Look this shameless man being confronted
by a real woman. Yes. He cannot be the
sandals. It cannot be the shoes
underneath the sister's feet. Yes. Okay.
And this sister showed true in Allah
subhana wa tala. Yes. Because she her
career is at risk. Yes. Her livelihood
is at risk. But her in is Allahh. She
knows Allah is the one who provides. And
Allah is going to give us something much
better. Like Omar he even mentioned on
Instagram. Let's watch in for the
confrontation. You have blood on your
hands. All of Microsoft has blood on its
hands. How dare you celebrate while
Microsoft is killing children. Shame on
you all. Thank you.
We cannot be celebrating while people in
Palestine are getting murdered thanks to
Microsoft. They could come after me, but
I think the fear of that
retaliation like does not counter the
fear of working on technology that bomb
innocents. Like for me my biggest fear
is like waking up from my 9 to5 and
realizing that my code might be killing
children today. So that's the the the
concern that was more prevalent for me
and that's why I spoke despite you know
knowing there might be consequences like
that. Yeah the fear of contributing to
the genocide in Gaza is greater for me.
I'm I'm more worried about Microsoft's
complicity and genocide honestly like
nothing is about like that is the limit
like knowing that our code is
50,000 people have died and Microsoft.
Thank you for your protest. I hear you.
This
will process. Thank you. Shame on you.
You are here. I hear you. Thank you.
on your
head. AI for good, but Microsoft sells
AI weapons to the Israeli military. You
are a war propheteer. Stop using AI for
genocide. Stop using AI for genocide in
our region. You have blood on your
hands. All of Microsoft has blood on its
hands. How do you all celebrate when
Microsoft is killing
children, people have died and Microsoft
genocide?
Thank you for your protest. I hear you.
You're serious. You know about this. You
are your protest. Thank you. Shame on
you. You are war propheter. Stop using
AI for genocide. Stop using AI for
genocide in our region. You have blood
on your hands. All of Microsoft has
blood on its hand. How dare you all
celebrate when Microsoft is killing
children.
Thank you. I hear your point. Thank you
all. You're all hypocrites. I'm a
Microsoft worker and I
Okay, so you've seen um this I mean it's
I mean what do you make out of that?
Like this guy is Mustafa. works for
Microsoft and he's he's from a Syrian
background. He knows what his people
have gone through and he's there like
the way he's like oh I hear your
protest. I mean what kind of a dirt bag
you have to I mean I'm I'm shocked you
are not even touched by that and you
said I hear your protest. What the
flipping hell does that mean bro? You're
from a Syrian background. You know what
people have gone through and there was
two confrontation I think on the day or
different places I don't know that uh
Indian lady what's her name I think Vana
Agraal. Yeah, she is the one. They were
viewing her, bro. They were literally
laughing at the crowd. What disgusting
people she is talking about 50,000
children and woman massacred and you're
there viewing her this that in the
crowd. And then you got Bill Gates the
flipping dirt back. He's not even he's
got his back towards he's not even
looking at her. Uh the scumbag who's
profiting of blood of these innocent
people. And subhan Allah this sister
wallah you just need to admire it. Bro,
this is a and it shows you anyone
anywhere could do. Look what she's done
is so profound. It's got to be
remembered in history. it that not only
is it profound, but I think it puts a
lot of people to shame because Microsoft
working at Microsoft, that's one of the
dream jobs. Yes. Of many people.
Microsoft, Apple,
Google. Yeah. If you get selected, it's
a big deal. Yes. Yeah. And your family
is going to be happy. And she comes from
abroad as well. So, there's two risks
there. Number one, she loses her job.
And number two, she gets deported. Yes.
Yeah. But then from the interviews as we
heard she said if I put that on one pan
of the balance and on the other pan of
the balance knowing that my code is
contributing to the to the killings of
children I'm not going to be able to she
can't and nobody in their right heart or
mind can sleep comfortably at night and
that's what it comes down to certain
people that have given priority to the
dunya frankly they have given priority
to their to their money and that money
that comes at the expense of people's
lives yes you may amass that money, but
that money is like ash. You know, a
little gentle gust of wind comes and
because there's no substance behind that
money, it scatters. Those people that
work and honest days living. They might
be earning a few bucks here and there,
but that money is like bricks. The wind
comes, can't move it. In other words,
baraka. People earn money through haram
means and think that because they've
accumulated it, it will be okay. But no,
they've accumulated it for the doctor.
They've accumulated it for the lawyer.
They've accumulated it for somebody
else, the doctor. They might fall ill
and they have to pay the doctor. They
might be embroiled in a you know
scandal. So they have to pay the lawyer
and the likes. There always is a means
of that money being removed from you.
Why? Because there is no baraka. That's
the same with this man and that's the
same with anyone that is contributing to
something that is not only haram but to
the killings of Muslims anywhere. Yeah.
And not only that, the thing is one
thing that I've noticed and we need to
understand this goes back to tohed is
that some some people look at her dress
set code and be like you know brother
you know she's not dressed or whatever
whatever shut the flipping up. Let me
put that here. She has more to than you
can in your life. You know why? Because
she by that statement is saying I don't
care about if it's Microsoft or
whatever. To her she's like for me it is
far worse knowing I wake up to my 9 to5
and they're using my codes to kill the
coding that I do for Microsoft killing
innocent people. To me, bro, that is the
that is it's a pinnacle of in Allah.
It's a pinnacle of it's a it's a
pinnacle of understanding what risk who
risk the risk comes from. Tuck like you
know when you're conscious of Allah
that's of course bro it's she's better
than that Mustafa that clown over there
standing there like a flipping I
hear your protest bro spit in your face
bro she has more honor more belief in
Allah more to than you can ever be and
you're from a Syrian background you
flipping dirt bag. Yeah you should be
ashamed of yourself. Okay. She has
moreed in her wall than in like I've
seen most people, Subhan Allah. Yeah.
Most people they just talk they just
talk she's understood what Allah means.
She doesn't care about losing the job.
She's like I'm feel sorry that Microsoft
listen she's like I'm all worried about
Microsoft being completed on the
genocide. It's going to go down in
history. She's even concerned about that
brother and sisters. So to me this is
what you call the epidome this this
pinnacle of tohed understanding who your
lord is having tawak that you know what
Microsoft is not the one who pays my
bills Microsoft is not the one that
gives me baraka Microsoft is not the one
that makes my heartbeat and it's not the
one that gives me my money and she knows
that Allah will give her something far
better far better and that is the
promise of Allah subhanaa tala that if
you leave something for the sake of
Allah Allah will give something better
may Allah honor our sister may Allah
bless and preserve her inshallah and
shame on you must mustafa put in your
face you dirt bag. You cannot be the
sandal underneath the dust underneath
her feet. Wall. And may Allah bless our
sisters and our brothers who are
actively doing something. That statement
there is powerful bro. So may Allah
bless and preserve you guys. Inshallah.
We want to do a reaction video to this.
And honor our sister. If she's watching
this, most likely she would. Salute to
you. You are more of a man than this
coward Mustafa little peasant little uh
uh This intellectual flipping
making AIDS carrying on working
at Microsoft. May Allahh deal with you.
You've got blood in your hands. May they
haunt you. Those kids screams and cries,
may they haunt you, Mustafa, you dirt
bag. That's what you
are. The prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said, "Whoever builds a masjid
for the sake of Allah subhanaa tala,
Allah will build for him a similar house
in Jenna on that day where Allahhana
tells us that our books will be given
and every little atom weight of good
deed we've done will be there." And
imagine you see a mountain and you're
like what a lucky person. Which
righteous person? And Allah says, "This
is for you." For me? Yes. What did I do?
You allowed people to pray. You built a
masid. I never had the money to build a
masid. Oh, Allah. You helped. You gave
towards it. And Allah gives you the
reward of as if you've built it. Donate
now, guys, and do not delay. And share
the video for extra rewards.
[Music]